hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about the two different types of
speciation that is allopatric speciation
and sympatric speciation but first let's
talk about speciation itself speciation
is just the origin of a new species and
in most cases it leads to or is a result
of reproductive isolation that is one of
the things that makes them a distinct
species is the inability to reproduce
with members of another species now
let's talk about allopatric speciation
allopatric comes from the greek for
different homeland and that's a clue in
allopatric speciation gene flow is
interrupted by geographic isolation gene
flow simply means the flow of genetic
information between individuals so for
example the Galapagos finches and other
animals that are on the Galapagos
Islands are a good example with
allopatric speciation this is because
most of them are related to other
species on the mainland meaning that
they shared once upon a time a common
ancestor with this other species but
they've been geographically isolated at
one point one of their ancestors made it
from the mainland to one of the islands
in the Galapagos and mutations were
acquired and various physical
characteristics were changed over time
that led to the census being different
species after being geographically
isolated from the parent species another
example of this is squirrels that live
on the north or south side of the Grand
Canyon you can imagine that two
squirrels the Grand Canyon presents a
major geographic isolation the squirrels
are too small to get from one side of
the canyon to another and so over time
after the canyon form you have the
squirrels on the North Face of the
canyon and the squirrels on the South
face of the canyon developing into
different species let's think about what
this might look like in a pictorial way
here the black represents two different
geographic habitats so we've got animals
that are separated by a geographic
isolation event perhaps it is plate
tectonics creating a mountain range
perhaps it is water levels and a lake
changing so that a large lake is now
made is now sunk into a few different
distinct ponds but what can happen there
is you have individuals in one of the
habitats developing into one species and
individuals and the other habitat
developing into a different species as a
result of the geographic isolation so
that is allopatric speciation in
sympatric speciation the chain flow
between individuals is reduced by some
other means so not geographic isolation
but the gene flow is reduced in
geographically overlapping populations
for example if you have a habitat where
two different species are forming from a
parent species it would look something
like this
where the two species are forming
despite being in a geographically
overlapping range examples of this in
plants include different types of
polyploidy remember that polyploidy is
rare and animals with pretty common
plants and it is a result of mistakes
during cell division that result in the
daughter plants having extra sets of
chromosomes so if you have two plants
that develop extra sets of chromosomes
around the same time they can mate with
each other leading to plant offspring
that also have you different
of chromosomes and these can result in
different species within the same
geographic location another example of
sexual selection in animals
so for example there are certain insects
that prefer to live on a certain type of
tree and this may allow them to diverge
as a new species from insects that
prefer to live on a different type of
tree for example insects that prefer to
eat from a certain type of flower and
then they're more likely to reproduce at
that flower this can eventually lead to
a different type of species forming
because of this type of sexual selection
also things like coloration patterns
whenever you have females of the species
that prefer males that have a certain
coloration pattern made birds and fish
have this kind of sexual selection this
over time can lead to different species
despite the fact that the individual
populations are overlapping so this is
the difference in allopatric speciation
which means different homeland and
sympatric speciation meaning same
homeland but they are both ways that a
new species can form and they both
involve some kind of reproductive
isolation instead patryk speciation the
reproductive isolation happens first and
this allows the new species to form in
allopatric speciation
there's the geographic isolation first
and then over time because of various
mutations the reproductive isolation can
follow so that is it for this episode of
biology professor thanks for watching I
hope you learned a lot